[Music]
my husband and i have always had a rule
we don't buy anything without telling
the other some argue that's silly but we
were a young couple that already had
children when we got married and didn't
make a lot money problems can break a
relationship real quick um yeah i think
there's two things that ruin a
relationship very quickly money problem
sex problems right there are others as
well we've been going around the country
doing this tour and i've been reading
this section
and i talk about all the problems in
this couple's relationship that we
interviewed for the book for love people
use things
and we had this couple in minneapolis
they had all these money troubles but
that was sort of the top layer covering
this entire labyrinth of deeper troubles
in their relationship
sex life was non-existent although when
they first met they were like rabbits
right and then over a decade later it
was like oh i'm kind of repulsed even
thinking about it that's not a place you
want to be in a relationship you want
love you want like and you want lust if
you want your relationship to thrive if
you have all three of those components
right well one of the ways to sort of
destroy all three of those
money problems not being on the same
page with respect to money
now the best way is to be reading from
the same book
we talked about this during the minimal
episode this week but
what do i mean by that having partnering
up with someone if you're going to be in
a partnership with someone a business
partnership a romantic relationship
even a really close friendship i think
it makes sense to have similar values
especially foundational values and the
structural values you can download our
free values worksheet by the way the
minimalists.com
v as in values there's an essay there
called how to understand your values we
talk about the four different types of
values including the imaginary values
and that's what i want to talk to sarah
about today ryan i want to talk to sarah
about quite often where we
run into trouble with our significant
other is because we value different
things or more important we think we
value different things
and so we think we certain things are
going to be really important to us if i
just have that 3 000
tag cuer
wristwatch then i'm going to be happier
more complete right
nothing wrong with owning that
wristwatch but if you're making that
purchase and forsaking the needs of the
family or the needs of the relationship
or the needs of your household or maybe
you're not paying rent our good friend
andy davis has that great line his song
good life we struggle to pay rent
because jeans are expensive
and what does that mean what means we
misprioritize
we save our genes are valuable to us and
yeah i i'm wearing blue jeans or black
jeans right now right but
i don't spend you know twelve hundred
dollars on ball main genes either
because
well a because i don't need to
but b because that's not a real value of
mine even if i really thought that those
looked great on me
it'd be a
i don't value those the same way i value
having financial freedom yeah having
savings you know an emergency fund
investing in my retirement these are
things that i value more than the sort
of surface level things and even if
fashion
is a surface value for you you don't
want to forsake your deeper values your
foundational values your structural
values
just to maintain the surface the analogy
that i often use has to do with painting
a house
great you want to paint a house beautify
your house make your house look
beautiful
if it's infested by termites
painting the house isn't going to fix
the structural damage that is being done
right now yeah and so we have to address
the structural damage first how do we do
that with a partner well i know ryan
i've set up some well not ibex and i
have set up in our own relationship some
ground rules that help us
with our own spending one is we don't
bring anything into the house
that we don't both agree on bex isn't
gonna go out and buy a brand new dresser
or in table or a coffee table and
neither am i a new set of chairs without
discussing it together first in fact
just this week ryan we uh over christmas
we um we have these two water bottles i
have a water bottle she has water bottle
we use it in the sauna we use it when
we're traveling there were these now
jean waddle water bottles and we brought
them we went to palm springs for
christmas you know so we have some
something to drink in the car
well at the last minute she accidentally
left them in the hotel room
we called tried to find them we've had
these for years
they um they couldn't find them yeah
they're gone and so
at first
uh we're talking about even with
something as trivial as seemingly benign
as water bottles
we make sure we are on the same page
because we want to make this purchase
once
intentionally
and i'll even spend a little bit more to
get the one that i need so i don't ever
have to make this purchase again unless
we leave them somewhere again which i
don't plan on doing and so what we have
done we still haven't even bought the
water bottles because it was like okay
we can replace them with the same exact
bottles in fact she sent me a few
pictures hey what about this one and at
first i even felt annoyed
because she sent me one i'm like doesn't
she know my taste better than that
because what do you say ryan you always
say like well we all want to be
understood yeah right yeah i want you to
understand
me
and at that moment i felt so
misunderstood because she sent me this
now jean bottle but had a blue top on it
who the hell wants a bright blue top on
their water bottle
god you're making me feel terrible
oh my goodness and and she knows even
aesthetically like this isn't her top
choice either but it's all i could find
right now and but she
she knows that like we're sending these
back and forth because until we both
agree on something we're not going to
bring this into our home and if we do
that for something as simple as a couple
water bottles
we're both satisfied with the purchase
at the end of the day and we're also not
worried about bringing in something
that's going to be offensive to the
other person now what does that mean
that means sometimes we go without for a
period of time
unfortunately in our culture we've told
ourselves it's not okay to go without
going without means you're depriving
yourself okay maybe you are
temporarily depriving yourself but that
temporary deprivation is like fasting
you do that for a period of time instead
of bringing the junk into your life
instead of consuming the junk i would
rather fast so i could be deliberate i
could be intentional with whatever we do
bring into our home and then once i have
it i'm not worried about and so we're
still looking for the ideal water bottle
for us not the perfect water bottle but
the question is what is the one water
bottle i'm going to buy
that i don't have to think about
for the next five 10 15 years
and if i can figure that out
then i'm no longer worried about well
you know i bought it but i don't know if
it's that good i'm kind of annoyed by
this purchase now i've had it for a year
i want something that's better than this
i want something that is more
streamlined i need something with
bluetooth technology in it right voice
activated water bottle
coming to a uh one-click purchase store
near you yeah
oh that's great man i lo i had a black
clean canteen coffee mug
that um i really liked it was it looked
good
um matched my outfit
and i left it behind at this at uh
somewhere in
i don't know somewhere in malibu and
wasn't able to get it back so i tried to
find a black clean canteen and i
couldn't
and i just got i just whatever was
available like the generic silver with
the black top but i got but you know for
me though
um
it doesn't like like i've never looked
at that silver one and been like god i
wish i had that black one yeah you know
it's it's i'm able to i don't know kind
of move past it but hey what i love
about
what you're talking about with you and
bex and what sarah's talking about here
is
how
you're able to set up these boundaries
together
like that
is really what helps a relationship
thrive yeah is instead of like
being reactionary
and you know letting something get out
of hand it's like you kind of
get ahead of it and say hey what's our
boundary when it comes to this thing now
sometimes something will happen and then
you realize like oh wow we really should
set a boundary around this which is fine
yeah but um but yeah i just admire
i just admire the fight i admire the
fact that mariah and i are able to do
that i mean i can't even tell you
the relationships i used to be in man it
was like it was one where the highway
and most of it had to do with me like it
was me basically saying hey this is how
i want it to be and if it isn't this way
then i'm going to
be a jerk
um
but also i had you know partners you
know the partners
that i used to have where
they would yeah it was either their way
or not the highway it was either their
way or uh they make my life miserable
i remember one where that was explicitly
stated to you yeah pretty much uh and
and so i think here's the
here's the key to all of this whether
it's for sarah or anyone who's listening
to this
if you get to the point where you're
hiding purchases from one one another
or you're just hiding shame from one
another
then
that is
it's harming your relationship
and you
you can talk to someone else now if
they're judging your purchases and
saying i don't want you to have that you
shouldn't have any independence or
that's not what we're talking about here
what we're talking about is a
willingness to be open with your partner
to be truthful about your own desires
where do your desires come from having
them understand your desires you
understanding their desires and doing so
together because if you are sharing
resources that also means you need to be
intentional together you can't go off
spending resources separately if you are
also sharing your resources that's like
if you're all putting
uh if you're giving to the us bucket in
the middle of that relationship but
you're constantly taking from it
secretly
it's of course that's going to cause
discontent in the relationship yeah you
know we were uh we put out a call here
to a lot of our
um
patrons and other folks on social media
about things that have annoyed them and
i thought what was interesting here
andrew said that three days before his
wedding he found out uh or before a
wedding not his wedding he was going to
he found out meals at the reception
would be 100 110 dollars per person
and
that's a weird sort of surprise right so
like welcome to our wedding
yeah it's like paying uh you know a
cover fee to get into the wedding yeah
and uh you know i understand it but
what what the lesson of this any of
these surprises is
having some sort of clear
understanding
of what you're getting into
don't spring that on anyone whether it's
buying a watch
or it is buying a new sofa or it's
asking someone to come to your wedding
and then sort of charging them at the
last minute or even worse like if you go
to an activity together
and then you know the next day you get
like a venmo request
hey you remember that uh sandwich we
split
uh i've seen a venmo request for three
dollars please
yeah
oh man it makes me think about um
mariah had gone out with a friend and it
was a big group of girls
and uh
this girl covered the whole meal or
whatever and like mariah had tried to
pay but they were like no i got it don't
worry about it
and then the next day she sends mariah a
venmo request for like 50 bucks
oh wow so she wanted the virtue signal
that's unbelievable yeah and then she
and mariah was like i only
because they were all drinking mariah
doesn't drink because yeah her stomach
problems so like mariah only got you
know maybe 10 bucks 20 bucks or
something
that's unbelievable and it was funny
because i'm right she's like what do i
do
i'm like you know
you could have this confrontation is it
worth
the 20 or the 30
to have this confrontation yeah i'd pay
50 to get rid of that friend exactly so
that's basically what she did she said
the 50 bucks and i was like just never
talked to her again like it's fine it
was
yeah it was really it was really shady
but dude this is cr i i think i don't
know man piece of me would just be like
you know what i guess we're not going to
come to your or i wouldn't eat at the
wedding maybe that would be it like
yeah i think i'll just bring a
cheeseburger
i packed my own dinner oh that'd be so
good if like andrew showed up with a
happy meal
during the reception
yeah and i mean there were all these
other annoyances people brought up as
well like uh sarah said i have a few
items of clothing that were surprise
purchases i do try to resell anything i
don't want on ebay or makari but
sometimes it's a slow process now so i
think
yes
a surprise purchase in the sense that
like it was an impulse purchase right oh
i really thought that dress looked great
on that mannequin therefore it will look
great on me
uh megan said any present that someone
gives me that is decor related is likely
going to be an unwelcome surprise
amen i agree with that and i i have one
exception that proves this rule um so uh
our publisher
although they didn't really surprise
this is interesting our our publisher
celadon
they um
they gave us this like little piece of
pottery
uh artwork
and it had a little celadon logo and
it's in celadon green is even the color
that it is they they had a local artist
i think in in new york city
who worked on this and
but even beforehand they're like hey we
usually give this to any of our authors
but i don't know if you guys would
or you're the minimalist you really want
it and i'm like sure it's a piece of art
and it seems really intentional and
beautiful yeah and so it's the one thing
that someone has given me where i
actually still display it yeah and
that's great but most of the time if you
get me something it it's essentially
giving me clutter yeah it is a um
man it's just it's a risky gift like i
would never give you
a p unless i was like 100 positive like
oh
he's going to use this like he gave you
gave me a picture of me and mariah
and uh i just played the photograph it's
great yeah frame photographs and that's
great like i totally frame that's a
beautiful picture it's it's funny it's
it's good
um but yeah i've had like
i've had people who
give me a box of decorations
like
yeah
vases and um
little cups and like little i don't know
my my mom does this a lot and sometimes
like it's great but like yeah the vast
majority of the time i'm like mom i love
you
but
i'm gonna have to find these a better
home yeah or like when my grandma tried
to give me that paperweight yeah
just gifting someone a piece of uh home
decor is always going to be a risky move
i love the paperweight
because it's
literal she tried to give you paperwork
but it's also like a metaphor for any
unwanted wanted we that's what the
metaphor we use we call it oh well it's
just a paperweight now right and what
that means is it's essentially useless
right it's best use is to hold down
papers
one other thing here um
holly brings up a great point she said
online auctions can quickly turn into
surprise purchases and what she means
here is that you get caught up in the
moment
that you see something that is on ebay
or if you go to a real auction and
you're like oh i really want to buy
that set of baseball cards or pokemon
cards whatever it is right
and it's a hundred dollars for this set
right
that's the starting bid but then someone
else bids 110. someone else bids 120.
now you're caught up in it well i've
already it's i've already committed so i
should go 130 at least right it's only
30 more dollars no it's not it's 130
more dollars at this point and all of a
sudden the bidding's up to 250 and
you're like oh should i do 260. it's
only 10 more dollars no it's 260 more
dollars than the zero that you've spent
right now and it's hard to walk away in
those moments because we get so caught
up in the excitement we get caught up in
the moment we get caught up in the
impulse and
what are we afraid of most
as humans we are afraid of loss
and in that moment there is this
perceived loss if i don't bid on this
car right now on this t-shirt right now
on this dress right now i really want
those coffee mugs that i saw on ebay or
what about that piece of pottery what
about the paperweight i want to buy it's
only x dollars and all of a sudden i'm
committed to it because the fear of
living without even though i've lived
without it forever i don't own it right
now
the fear of not having it at this point
is so great
that i'm willing to spend irrationally
to get something that i never even had
in the first place
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
free